>> Dana: DEMOCRATIC LEADERS
REFUSING TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THE CRIME CRISIS, BLAMING
THE NEW YORK GOVERNOR CATHY
HOPEFUL FOR THE EXECUTION-STYLE
MURDER OF A MOTHER WITH THREE
CHILDREN, AND SHOT AND KILLED IN
FRONT OF HER KIDS BY HER
ESTRANGED HUSBAND.
LESS THAN 24 HOURS AFTER HE WAS
RELEASED WITH NO BAIL OVER THIS
VERY BRUTAL BEAT DOWN THAT SHE
POSTED TO HER FACEBOOK PAGE AND
A DESPERATE PLEA FOR HELP.
THE GOVERNOR REFUSING ANY
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
COLD-BLOODED MURDER AND BLAMING
A SYSTEM THAT SHE RUNS.
TO SPEAK OF THE SYSTEM
ABSOLUTELY FAILED HER, AND THE
SYSTEM HAS TO WORK.
ORDERS OF PROTECTION HAVE TO BE
GRANTED.
TRANSITION HOMES HAVE TO BE
AVAILABLE, AND WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT JUDGES AND PROSECUTORS
CHARGE APPROPRIATELY.
>> Dana: AS LEE ZELDIN CLOSES
IN THINGS TO CONCERNS, DEMOCRATS
ARE CALLING AND VICE PRESIDENT
KAMALA HARRIS AND
HILLARY CLINTON FOR A LAST DITCH
PUSH FOR KATHY HOPEFUL.
THINKING THAT THE G.O.P. IS
TRYING TO SCARE VOTERS.
>> SO WHEN THEY TALK ABOUT
CRIME, THEY ARE JUST TRYING TO
GIN UP ALL KINDS OF FEAR AND
ANXIETY IN PEOPLE.
THEY ARE NOT DEALING WITH IT,
THEY ARE NOT TRYING TO TACKLE
IT, AND SO I VIEW IT AS AN
EFFORT TO SCARE VOTERS.
>> Dana: DO YOU WANT TO
COMMENT ON ANYTHING, BUT TO --
THAT WOMAN WHO WAS MURDERED IS
TERRIBLE.
>> I'M FURIOUS, WHEN THEY SAY
THAT WE ARE TRYING TO GIN UP
THIS ANGER, FIRST OF ALL YOU
HAVE TWO JOKES, TWO LOSERS,
HILLARY CLINTON AND
KAMALA HARRIS COMING IN.
REMEMBER THAT SHE'S AN
ACCIDENTAL GOVERNOR AND NO
CONSTITUENCY, NOBODY BELIEVES IN
HER.
SHE IS CORRUPT AS THE DAY IS
LONG, NOBODY HEARD OF HER.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT, SHE IS
CORRUPT, TALK ABOUT THE
BUFFALO BILLS AND THE STADIUM
AND THEN TALK ABOUT THE TEST
THAT SHE GAVE THE NO GOOD
CONTRACT AND WE PAY DOUBLE THE
PRICE, BUT LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT
THIS NINCOMPOOP SAYS, SHE SAYS
THAT WE HAVE TO TRUST THE
SYSTEM.
WE HAVE TO GET ORDERS OF
PROTECTION, LET ME TELL YOU
SOMETHING, GOVERNOR, AN ORDER OF
PROTECTION IS A PIECE OF PAPER,
AND RUNNING THAT THE VIOLENCE IN
THE UNIT IN THE NATION, ISSUE
THESE PIECES OF PEOPLE TO LET
MEN PAPER MYSELF, JUST GAVE IT
TO THE VICTIMS, SAME TO THE COPS
THIS MAN NEEDS TO BE ARRESTED
BECAUSE HE CAN PREDICT THE
HOMICIDE.
IF ANYONE WATCHES A VIDEO OF
THAT WOMAN BEING BEAT DOWN BY
THAT MAN, THERE IS NO QUESTION
OF HIS INTENT TO KILL HER.
SO WHY WAS HE CHARGED WITH AN
ASSAULT THREE?
WHY WAS HE CHARGED WITH A
MISDEMEANOR AS OPPOSED TO LOOK
AT THAT ANIMAL.
AS OPPOSED TO ATTEMPTED MURDER
OR ASSAULT IN THE FIRST DEGREE,
A RISK OF DEATH?
SHE DOES NOT KNOW WHAT SHE IS
TALKING ABOUT.
THE LAW NEEDS TO BE CHANGED.
SHE NEEDS TO CHANGE IT.
THERE IS BLOOD ON HER HANDS WITH
THIS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIM
AND ALTOGETHER, WITH 25 RISKS
WHO RAPES OTHER WOMEN.
THEY OWN AND I WILL PAY FOR IT
ON ELECTION DAY.
>> Dana: IT IS STRANGE WHEN
YOU HAVE HILLARY CLINTON SAY
THAT ON THE DAY THAT YOU HAVE
THE MURDER THAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT, BUT YOU BROUGHT UP A MAN
WHO HAD BEEN ARRESTED OVER 25
TIMES, RAPES A WOMAN JOGGING AT
4:30 IN THE MORNING IN WEST
VILLAGE IN HER NEIGHBORHOOD.
>> Greg: 32 THIS YEAR.
>> Dana: SO WHEN REPUBLICANS
ARE TRYING TO GENET UP, WHERE
DOES SHE GET THAT?
>> Jessica: I DID NOT THINK
THAT THAT WAS THE RIGHT RESPONSE
TO THIS.
I THINK THAT SAYING THAT YOU CAN
TEMPER YOUR MESSAGE AND SAY THAT
IT IS NOT NEW YORK CITY IS NOT
THE THAT SOME PEOPLE WOULD HAVE
YOU BELIEVE THAT IT IS, AND
THAT'S HOW I FEEL ABOUT IT, BUT
I AM NOT BLIND TO WHAT IS GOING
ON, AND YOU ARE SEEING THESE
THINGS HAPPEN IN ALL THE PLACES
THAT YOU FREQUENT, WHICH IS
MARKEDLY DIFFERENT FROM HOW
CRIME WAVES HAVE HAPPENED.
AND IT WAS ISOLATES AND WORSE IN
TECHNICAL TERMS, IN TERMS OF
PEOPLE BEING MURDERED, BUT IT
WAS ISOLATED IN PLACES AND YOU
KNEW WHERE NOT TO GO, NOW IT IS
IN THE WEST VILLAGE OUT THERE IT
IS SUPER FANCY OVER THERE.
IT IS PEOPLE JOGGING AND
LULULEMON PUSHING BABIES.
>> Dana: A LOT OF THESE
VICTIMS ARE WOMEN, IT'S WOMEN
BEING ATTACKED, YOU DON'T HAVE
THE CONGRESSWOMAN OR THE SENATOR
FROM NEW YORK SAYING ANYTHING.
>> Greg: THIS IS NOT THE FIRST
TIME THAT HILLARY HAS THROWN
WOMEN UNDER THE BUS, BUT IT
MIGHT BE THE WORSE.
AND THE IDEA, I WOULD UNDERSTAND
IF SUDDENLY "THE FIVE" JUST
STARTED TALKING ABOUT CRIME A
WEEK OR SO BEFORE NOVEMBER,
RIGHT?
NO, WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THIS FOR TWO AND A HALF YEARS
SINCE THIS STUFF HAS BEEN GOING
ON.
YOU KNOW, SHE KNOW SHE IS IN
TROUBLE AND I HOPE SHE LOSES,
NOW SHE IS SAYING THAT SHE
ACKNOWLEDGES THE CRIME PROBLEM.
SO WHAT SHE HAS DONE, SHE IS
ACKNOWLEDGING ITS, SHE HAD AMPLE
WARNING THAT IF SHE HAD LISTENED
ABOUT THIS BAIL REFORM THAT WAS
HORRENDOUS, THAT MOTHER OF THREE
WOULD BE ALIVE.
SO SHE HAD ACTUALLY DONE HER
JOB, THAT PERSON WOULD BE ALIVE.
YOU CAN'T CHARGE SOMEONE FOR
MURDER WHEN YOU LET SOME BUDDY
DIE, BUT SHE LET THEM DIE.
SHE LET THIS HORRENDOUS PRACTICE
KEEP GOING AND SAID SHE WOULD
REVISIT IT I GUESS IN JANUARY,
WELL, WHY?
BECAUSE SHE ASSUME SHE IS GOING
TO WIN AND THEN COME JANUARY SHE
DOES NOT HAVE TO DEAL WITH IT
ANYMORE.
REINSTATING CASH BAIL COULD BE
THE EASIEST THING YOU CAN DO
UNLESS YOU ARE A SPINELESS DRIP
WHO COWERS BEFORE VOLK SOROS
PROGRESSIVE PROSECUTORS.
FOR HER IT'S HARDER THAN
CLIMBING MOUNT EVEREST IN HIGH
HEELS, BUT NOT HARDER FOR
ANYBODY ELSE.
DOES NOT EVEN MATTER IF IT IS
LEE ZELDIN, DOES NOT EVEN MATTER
IF IT'S REPUBLICANS, COULD BE
DEMOCRATS.
A NEW PERSON COMES IN AND CAN DO
IT BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
BAGGAGE.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE SUNK COST,
THEY DON'T HAVE THE BLOOD ON
THEIR HANDS.
SO I THINK TUESDAY, THEY HAVE TO
VOTE AS IF THEIR LIVES DEPENDED
ON IT, BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY IT
DOES.
>> Dana: ITS DEMOCRATS
REALIZING THEY DON'T HAVE
OPPOSING ARGUMENTS THAT
REPUBLICANS WILL CUT
SOCIAL SECURITY AND MEDICARE,
THAT IS PREPOSTEROUS AND YOU CAN
ASK ANYBODY ABOUT THAT.
WHAT ABOUT PRESIDENT BIDEN?
SPENDING THE ENTIRETY TRYING TO
TELL VOTERS THAT HE DID NOT
ARTHUR THE 1994 CRIME BILL,
MAYBE NOW HE WISHES HE HAD NOT
DONE THAT.
>> Jesse: WAS TRYING TO WIN
PRAISE FROM THE BASE, AND THIS
IS WHY KATHY IS GOING DOWN,
BECAUSE SHE HAD TO GET CORNERED
BY THE MEDIA DAYS AFTER THE
STORY BROKE TO EVEN SAY ANYTHING
ABOUT THIS.
YOU ARE A FEMALE GOVERNOR OR A
LEADER IN THE STATE, THIS WAS A
MASSIVE STORY FOR THE LAST 48
HOURS AND YOU HAVE TO GET
CORNERED IN A DARK CORNER AND
JUST FINALLY SAY SOMETHING AND
BLAME THE SYSTEM.
SHE IS THE SYSTEM AND THEN HER
POINTS, THEY KILLED THE WOMAN,
BUT REELECT ON TUESDAY, THAT
DOES NOT MAKE ANY SENSE.
SHE WAS LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR WHEN
ANDREW CUOMO SIGNED THE BAIL
REFORM.
AND THEN A DEBATE LAST WEEK, SHE
CHAMPIONED AL BRAGG AND SAID
THAT I HAVE HIS BACK.
AND HE WAS THE ONE THAT UNDER
CHARGE THIS MONSTER DOWN TO A
MISDEMEANOR AND THEN GETS OUT
AND KILLS HER.
SO THERE IS BLOOD ON OUR HANDS,
AND DOES NOT HAVE THE HEART OR
THE BRAIN TO DO THE JOB.
SHE'S LIKE IF THE TEN MEN AND
THE SCARECROW, IT'S NOT GOING TO
CUT IT, LADY.
SHE IS IN TROUBLE, BECAUSE YOU
ARE BRINGING IN HEAVY HITTERS TO
DEEP BLUE NEW YORK, CROOKED,
LAW, AND THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE
THE SAFEST GOVERNOR'S SEAT EVER,
YOU'RE BRINGING THE BIG DOGS
NOW!
SHE IS GOING DOWN.
>> Jessica: CAN I ASK QUICKLY
ABOUT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THAT IT
REALLY BOTHERS ME AND THERE WAS
THE CASE IN NEW YORK, THE WOMAN
OUT OF SHELTER HIDING FROM HER
PARTNER AT WHEN SHE WAS PUSHING
THE BABY STROLLER, EVERYONE WHO
TALKS ABOUT THIS ACTS LIKE IT'S
NO BIG DEAL AND TELL PEOPLE TO
MOVE, YOU SHOULD PICK UP AND
RESTART YOUR LIFE, THIS WOMAN,
THE MOTHER, HER MOTHER HELPS
TAKE CARE OF THE CHILDREN.
YOU CAN'T JUST GO SOMEWHERE AND
SUDDENLY YOU HAVE BUILT IN
CHILD CARE AND ABANDON YOUR
HOME.
SPEWING THAT'S WHY THE WOMEN IN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SITUATIONS
ALWAYS WANT TO GO HOME.
THEY WILL LIVE IN A TRANSITION
HOME OR SHELTER, BUT THEY WANT
TO GO HOME TO GET THEIR CHILDREN
A NORMAL LIFE.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS ABOUT THIS
THAT IS SO OUTRAGEOUS IS THAT
THE POLICE COMMISSIONER AGREED
THAT THE GOVERNOR NEEDS TO
CHANGE AND DO SOMETHING ABOUT
BAIL LAWS.
MAYOR ADAMS KEPT HIS MOUTH SHUT
AND SAID NOTHING.
I MEAN, THE POLITICAL IDEOLOGY
THAT IS RUNNING THE DEMOCRATS IN
THIS STATE IS HURTING --
>> Dana: AND WHERE THE WOMEN
ELECTED LEADERS?